we'll call the meeting to order
everyone present is seated
need a motion for the minutes
move to approve
second
motion by mcguire second by ward
any additions deletions or corrections
to the minutes
seeing none all those in favor opposed
the motion carries
motion for the consent agenda
yes
i'd like to remove the first item the
child support payments
from the consent agenda
okay
2021-117 is removed from the consent
calendar
any discussion on the balance of the
consent calendar
move to approve
and motion by mcguire ii by gray
any discussion
all those in favor
opposed
the motion carries
is this a long
thing on your
removal
i don't know
okay um
we'll start with item 7 the board of
dental examiners
mr chairman this is an emergency rule
from the board of dental examiners
what this rule does is currently by rule
only 40 percent of
continuing education units
for dentists can be done by
online by webinars
given that there right now is
very limited access to such in-person
seminars to live seminars
the board is put forth this emergency
rule that would for 180 days
allow
100 percent online women live webinars
to be used for credits the concern is
that dentists are not going to be able
to meet their requirements
to renew their licenses
and it's going to reduce the number of
dentists available
plus cause economic harm to those
dentists
the committee
there was a similar rule by one of the
other boards a few months ago
any discussion
is there anybody here from the dental
i don't believe so they had asked staff
if it was necessary i'm sorry
good morning i'm tina kelly i'm here to
represent the board of dental examiners
i'm the
program specialist with oplc and i'll be
glad to ask any ques answer any
questions you might have
can we expect this situation to be
corrected in the near future
it's anticipated this this will be the
only time this emergency role will be
needed
at the present time they're not doing
live courses but they will be going back
to those so i anticipate that this will
rectify them rectify itself
okay thank you
yes
i just have a quick question i don't
know if miss kelly knows but proximantis
are affected by this this year
this would probably and i don't know the
number of dentists there are licensed in
the state but it is my anticipation that
this changing this rule or not changing
this rule would affect all the dentists
because they have to get a certain
number
through live courses thank you
okay
next we're going to take up item 9
department of agriculture
mr chairman
depending whether you're looking at to
the agenda that's on
online or the one that had been sent out
by email there is an error in items nine
and ten and
says response net yet not yet received
response due by april 26th
that uh is not the case we have received
the objection response just in the last
day or two
that is applicable however to item nine
we have not yet received the objection
response
for 2021-104
but christina can talk to you about or
2021-107
and the objection response
okay so 104 goes to the next meeting
yes
that's item nine
and
go right ahead
um objection response uh 2021-107
is on uh the licensure of architects
and um the committee staff no longer
have any comments the the agency did a
great job of
eliminating the unclear comments with
the forms from previously i just have a
note to gelcar because originally there
was an inadequate
fiscal impact statement
this was because in between the ip and
the fp
the um fees for these licenses changed
and there wasn't an updated fiscal
impact statement there is now and that
is attached in your packet so um
everything has been
or all concerns of committee staff have
been eliminated
motion
move to approve
second
motion by lying second by gray any
discussion
all those in favor aye
opposed
okay
board of education
item 103
school year in distance education
uh 103 uh committee staff have no
comments
i think it's it's on the agenda because
we were anticipating
public testimony
one section of the rule deals with
remote education there's a general
prohibition with some limited exceptions
and we didn't know if that would cause
any public testimony or not
otherwise it would have been on the
consent item
is there anybody
present who wishes to speak to this
yes no
i see
okay
so move to approve
second
motion by mcguire second by lang any
discussion
all those in favor aye
opposed
motion carries
item 102 education freedom accounts
mr chairman before we start to discuss
this rule we need to take a preliminary
procedural vote
when
our office received the conditional
approval request
it was less than the seven day
required by statute
in that instance the department can
request the committee to still take up
the conditional approval response
and i have to say it was by no fault of
the department that the conditional
approval was late
they received our final proposal
comments quite late and simply did not
have the time to fashion a conditional
approval response before the seven day
limit passed okay we need a motion to
accept the rule
second accepted by
gray second by maguire any discussion
all those in favor aye aye opposed
whoever speaking for the department
identify yourselves
frank edelblut commissioner of education
chris bond attorney for the department
of education
mike
thank you mr chairman
i'll run through the issues as quickly
as i can
if you're looking at the text online
you first have a 10-page letter from the
board and
can you put his microphone on please
turn it off
is this better
the first 10 pages of the proposal here
is a letter from the commissioner
discussing
comments by
ols staff
by jerry zellen
and by
the aclu
and the first
six and a half pages of the text is just
struck through
substantive comments by committee staff
start on page nine
and i have to admit that i'm winging
this a little bit it was kim's rule she
is out sick today so i'm picking it up
the first comment is at the top of page
nine
we don't have a specific concern with
the language of
this paragraph it just we felt was the
appropriate place to
put the comment below
which was a
concern about the broad language in 194
f2
roman 2 0.
f2 2 lists
the items that can be educational
expenses that can be approved by the
scholarship organization
the paragraph o is a catch-all that says
any other educational expense approved
by the scholarship organization
we're concerned that a lack of criteria
here
would allow
carte blanche to the
scholarship organization to approve or
disapprove other items
the board
the department's position is that you
know this is legislative intent this
statute authorizes the scholarship
organization to do this
but we're concerned that
the scholarship organization is actually
a vendor for the state
and is
spending state money without
adequate direction
there is no criteria about
what can be covered and what cannot
i presume the committee would like
us to take these one at a time
and allow the agency to respond yes
great thank you for that um so one
clarification um so
as the comment was summarized there's an
indication that there is no criteria for
the scholarship organization to be able
to adjudicate whether or not a
expense through the education freedom
account is eligible or not and we would
assert that there is criteria in the
statute as it was crafted by the
legislature and that comes across in a
couple of different ways
first there is an enumerated list
of expenses it's a through o o being the
last item and if you see in our response
we've quoted
some case law on this that
o can't be taken out of the context of
being part of a list and say like when
it says any other eligible expenses it
doesn't mean they can just or any other
expenses they can just go out and spend
it on anything they want they have to be
in the context of that list
and then if you go and you look at um
you know the reference in
194 f22
it is enumerated in their what are types
of eligible expenses what are we
supposed to be spending it says to
provide an education for an eligible
student in the core knowledge domains
that include science mathematics
language government history health
readings uh writing spelling uh history
of the constitutions of new hampshire in
the united states and exposure to
appreciation of the arts and music so
for example if a particular student said
well i want to spend money on how to
become an airline pilot well i don't see
that fitting into these categories here
so we think that there is appropriate
constraining language
for
the scholarship organization to be able
to have criteria to apply this as we go
forward and then the final point that i
will make is that the department also
has a programmatic monitoring so we will
be reviewing expenses at the back end of
this and auditing to make sure that they
are eligible expenses so i believe that
there are plenty of constraints in place
and that
you know the legislature by creating
that o category is acknowledging that
it's not possible to enumerate every
expense that some student may use
eligibly on educational expenses so
there's this catch-all rather than us
trying to enumerate it and i don't
believe it was the legislature's intent
for an agency to narrow down what those
expenses might be by us coming up with
our own determination of what other
expenses might look like
questions from the committee
so is is the middle ground
adding to the sentence
some of the
items that the commissioner uh suggested
in there and giving other expenses
consistent with and then adding
you know
at least a brief or or a reference to
the language
well so we would assert that that
broader language is already part of i
mean again it's got a long list of
expenses to begin with it starts a day
and goes all the way through a so it's
defining a lot of different types of
expenses that are eligible so us trying
to add to a list that goes from a
you know through o already i don't think
is going to add clarity
what we really need to understand is
that
they have to be educate you know
eligible education expenses but i'm not
sure and then is your question that we
should should put a negation here's
what's not allowed
if i mean mr chair
you read a statement that the education
expenses should be consistent with
and then you've read the statement yep i
said i read the law
what i'm suggesting is that instead of
just say other expenses that say other
expenses consistent with
and then put that statement that you
read either in
you know the words in or put a reference
to it in
and therefore you get what you want
he gets what he wants and we've crafted
that win-win that we're always seeking
right yeah um so i mean you know
certainly delcar can do what they want
if they think that's necessary i think
that that's already clear in the statute
and in the law we would basically what
would be happening is we would take rsa
192 f2 2
and restate the exact same language into
uh rsa 192 f22o so in other words like
so it's already in its contact site it
says here's the introductory here's the
broad categories of expenses and then
you've got enumerated lists of expenses
and so we would just take that paragraph
and reiterate the exact same paragraph
over again um so i'm not sure that that
it adds clarity per se
representative mcguire thank you
mr chair i don't think this is the right
place to put it in any case because this
paragraph
i is dealing with the
parent and education server provider
advisory commission which is responsible
for appeals
for denials and other expenses so
as long as there is anything that is not
specifically enumerated this paragraph
says there is a advisory commission
set up set up in statute which
deals with appeals and whether other
expenses are appropriate
so i think we don't need to say
here
that they have to be in accordance with
anything
thank you mr chair thank you mr chair
perhaps uh we could do it a little
different we could you know instead of
enumerating everything in the rule we
could just say something like um you
know that the expenses are limited to
those areas specifically in the statute
and then inside the statute would you
would you object to that
i i don't have an objection to that
because again you all can do
as you see fit but i think that
that's already in the statute it says
that these are the only things that you
can do with it and so we're reiterating
that's not my question so the reference
would be
you know that the expenses are limited
to those in the statute so it's a
limitation to what's in what you're just
saying what's listed in the statute yeah
so i think we already have that language
in there that we're saying you can only
spend it on these eligible expenses so
we are saying that i think that you
wouldn't object that putting that into
the rule then
i think it's already in the role
and i disagree okay
it's not in this location it may be
somewhere else senator
mike
i'm not sure that that senator whitley's
suggestion would clarify the problem
because if you just require compliance
with the statute well o in the statute
has that catch-all that's very broad i
mean the purpose of rules is to clarify
and implement statute
so that catch-all in the statute
hopefully would be fleshed out in the
rule i think senator gray had a pretty
good suggestion i'm not sure exactly
where it would go in the rules but to
say uh for the catch all in the rule to
say consistent with the
items
listed in a
above perhaps you should we should look
at on page 11 qualifying efa expenses
where it limits some of the items
and it goes on to say
you know
d under there which is at the top of
page 12 says a scholarship organization
shall publish on its website a policy
for pre-approval of qualifying
educational expenses consistent with
f2
oh and this section so that they would
list out
once people identify
other expen other qualifying expenses
they list them and say this is not
specifically enumerated but it's
appropriate
so so i think i agree with the
commissioner that it's already there
so just reflecting that's what i'm
saying is like i feel like we've already
pulled that into here and so you can
only do the things that are enumerated
i also just wanted to point out um ols
staff noted that the um the state is in
contractual privity with the scholarship
organization so we do the department
does have oversight through its contract
and um you know agencies don't manage
their contracts through administrative
rules so
scholarship organization is in constant
contact with the department over issues
like this and it is the department's
understanding that the
uh the
the list is limited that the catch-all i
mean the department's understanding is
that the as the commissioner said
the
uh the legislature
believed that there were it was
impossible to enumerate every
conceivable
uh educational expense that could be
consistent with the the core uh
provisions that are set forth and the
department would have the same problem
in limiting it there's a there's a
essential case-by-case nature of looking
at a lot of these and the department
thinks it would be contrary to the
legislative intent to somehow limit that
by uh constraining it but we we do have
this contractual privity and the
relationship with the scholarship
organization um so that the department's
understanding here will effectively be
the way the scholarship organization
manages this process
thank you mr chair
so i understand that you know there's
that contractual relationship with the
department and
a scholarship organization but would you
agree that you know the legislature has
a very important role and gialcar is a
very important role in
understanding how public funds are going
to be
spent and i'm particularly uncomfortable
with
such a broad catch-all that we would
have that were writing a blank check
essentially wouldn't you agree that the
legislature has an important role in
managing public funds
i would emphasize that the legislature
has the premier role in educating
managing those funds and our role is to
administer the laws that you've given us
so there is that category oh that says
other educational expenses because the
legislature
it appears determined that there's this
long list of a through o
o being we don't know what else might
come up but it has to fit into the
categories the broad categories of
eligible expenses that we've defined in
this law
and so what i'm trying to avoid is the
agency taking over the responsibility
that the legislature
acknowledges that there's this catch-all
required to administer this program
because all of a sudden then i'm sitting
in the seat of a legislator trying to
enumerate what those other categories
might be when the legislature clearly
had the intent of trying to enumerate as
much as they could come up with and then
adding another category so i i would say
that the actions of the agency are
deferring to the supremacy of the
legislature and trying to decide this
follow-up
thank you
so right so we have this catch-all it
you know as the agency can you
provide some information about what what
the department would consider uh
applicable to those
that catch all what expenses would fit
into that sure so anything that fits in
the categories a through you know up to
o lmnop
uh you know would would qualify right
and those you the legislature has
enumerated all of those um but there are
today
parents who are applying for expenses
and those are being rejected by the
scholarship organization those
rejections have the ability to go on
appeal to this commission that would
oversee those so there is a a mechanism
for re-looking at those but some of the
types of expenses that may be excluded
if somebody came along and said well i
would like to buy furniture
for my home so that my child can do
um you know their homework more
comfortably or and and therefore they
might even make the assertion that my my
child could be more effective at their
homework that wouldn't i've got my list
of a through
o uh that would not fit through a
through m
um n
and uh and so then it may so a parent
may try to fit it into category o but
then we would look to the statute which
says is this you know science math
language and we would adjudicate and say
like that's not an eligible expense
because it doesn't fit into the
categories that the legislature has
given us and so it would be rejected
and it hasn't been that difficult to
determine you know i start with my list
if i don't see it on the list and it
falls into oh i go to my broader
categories does it fit into these broad
categories that the legislature has
given us if it does not it's not an
eligible expense yeah so i don't think
you answered my question because you
have that enumerated list and then you
have a catch-all which is very broad so
you have indicated some areas that would
be excluded right but you haven't said
what are those areas that aren't
enumerated that might be caught up in
the catch-all what i'm concerned is the
breadth and the scope of the catch-all
and i think that's exactly what the job
car staff is telling us and so that's
the area that i haven't heard you've
said number of times enumerated that's
clear we're talking about the catch-all
here and in the rule
i believe that we need more clarity on
what would be included and what would
not be included in that very very broad
catch-all yeah so then i would just um
again reiterate we are trying not to sit
and usurp in any way the legislative
power
which was very clear in terms of their
enumeration and so for the agency to
then step in and make adjudications and
determine you know that
beyond the fact that you've given us
further guidance for o which is science
math language and etc right so that is
the frame through which we can look at
anything that wants to pass through o
has to meet that criteria and that's how
we understand that legislator that
legislation has been crafted
senator gray um
i don't agree with some of the things
that senator whitley has said
our job
our job here in jail car is to
take what the legislature did and i
supported that bill i voted for that
bill
and
put the rules together okay
we put that catch all in there
okay
and if we want to slightly give them
some more guidance
in this rule
similar to what i had said before is in
the proper place say consistent with the
other things that are in the bill that
makes sense
but to try and define it down to
a very fine point does not make sense
and it is in my opinion not consistent
with what we're supposed to do
in the rules committee thank you
representative mcguire
thank you
i'd like to ask the commissioner whether
or not he knows
whether the scholarship organization has
published
any qualifying expenses consistent with
paragraph o
which they're required to do by this
rule
yes i don't believe that that has been
published at this point in time so i
can't i don't know the answer to that
but i think but we will be publishing
that as it comes to i think that that
by publishing what qualifying expenses
have been considered to fall under that
catch-all
we will be able to determine if that's
too broad or not broad enough
because right now we don't have the data
we've just the program has just barely
started
and so i think that by
showing
that what rules are excuse me what types
of things qualify
for that section o
we will be able to answer senator
whitley's question and narrow it in
legislation if necessary
senator whitney thank you thank you so
um thank you for that clarification but
wouldn't
my concern and i think it's the concern
of the jail car staff is that you know
letting the scholarship organization
determine that scope would be sort of an
information impermissible delegation of
authority by the department of education
wouldn't you agree
actually the law specifically says that
the scholarship organization is
determining whether those are eligible
expenses you did not delegate that power
to us we do have oversight
responsibility so we can go in and do
programmatic monitoring um but in fact
we're trying to follow the law as
closely as possible with this
mr chair
representative representative thank you
i'm just trying to gather it all back in
so
the way i read this section d on here is
that it took section o which was
basically we didn't want to create a non
an exhaustive list we said here's a list
and then
here's if there's anything else that you
find that falls in because we didn't
think of it it goes on the category oh
is that the first am i getting that
first section right this is how we
understand the legislature having passed
it to us thank you follow up mr chair
follow up so and then what you've done
is taking that that direction from the
legislature that says there's here's our
you know we have a non-exhaustive list
here and get gave you the catch-all is
the scholarship organization will think
of the things that we didn't think of
and with the number of parents we have
uh out there that may come up with an
innovative idea it allows you to be able
to take that innovative idea decide
whether it falls within the education or
the scholarship program decide whether
it's an educational benefit to the child
and if it is it can be added under the
category of oh it'll then be published
to the website so any other parent who
want to think think about that same
thing will also be able to see oh that's
an allowed expense i can do that
is that and then that list will
ultimately grow
to so parents will be clear what what
things that the legislature didn't agree
with or didn't think of and put into the
the
list
uh that are eligible and also what's not
right they can choose if it's not a list
they can still apply and maybe add it or
not is that is that
the way you're anticipating is going to
flow i do and the only constraining
factor i have is just because a parent
brings something to us under o doesn't
mean that it's another eligible expense
is that eligibility adjudication takes
place when i go back to
194 f3 3d1 you know which is science
math and stuff like that right so if
they bring us something that doesn't fit
into these categories that you've given
to us then we would adjudicate that as
uneligible one last follow-up mr chair
and then lastly i i would i would
anticipate that your reviewing is part
of contract management all those things
that have been approved and if you see
something you disagree with you can you
can challenge that with the with a
scholarship organization or if a
legislator
sees something on that list that
disagrees with we can put a bill in and
and deal with that again adding
lmnop you know another item on the list
and and exclude something if we think
it's inappropriate is that how we see
this slowly rolling out and working
correct and as well then parents also
have a valve relief if they don't
believe it's correct then they have this
commission to be able to go and have
that evaluated and adjudicated as well
so thank you very much
go ahead mike
next item is on page 10.
um
kim had a large comment here um i've
read the department's response
i have to agree with them regarding
ferpa and much of what this says but
i have great concern with the intro
intro language to g
saying the scholarship organization
shall have access to confidential
student information
that doesn't say how the department has
indicated that that is going to be
requested on the application form that's
created by the scholarship organization
but as this is worded there's nothing to
prevent the scholarship organization
from going to a public school and saying
we want this student's records
so happy to respond to that so we have a
myriad of other laws that restrict the
ability of both leas as well as the sea
to disclose information even with
regulatory authority for the scholarship
organization to uh if if in fact that's
what you believe that they would be
asking for this confidential student
information um the body that control who
controls that information doesn't have
authority to turn it over
that's right but
as the word rule is worded it could an
attempt could be made it also would seem
to
indicate that scholarship organization
could
try to try to compel the parent to
provide this information
well when the when the department noted
in its response that
the scholarship organization will have
access to confidential information from
the parent
it it was simply trying to
articulate that when an application is
received the simple
biographical data of the applicant the
name the date of birth the address
that's all information that would be
considered confidential information if a
school held it under ferpa so just as a
matter of course if someone wants to
fill out their child's name put it on a
piece of paper and give it to the
scholarship organization that's
information that if a school had it they
would have to treat as a ferpa record
that's what we're trying to capture
we're not we weren't trying to
give any authority to the scholarship
organization to ask for anything
other than what was uh is is necessary
for their application to enroll a child
i i certainly understand and not trying
to suggest that
eligibility for uh the pro to
participate in the program um by
granting them the ability to do that it
does not then grant them the ability to
go anywhere they want and seek
confidential information
from
you know participants in the program and
we
do have
the ability to influence the application
and would not
allow an application with parents to go
forward that would be collecting
superfluous or unnecessary information
needed for a simple adjudication of
eligibility into the program
next item okay
on the next page page 10
paragraph i
again we're dealing with other
educational expenses approved by the
scholarship organization
kim's comment raises a concern about
the issue raised by the aclu and
attorneys ellen regarding this being so
broad that
religious instruction
might fall under this and uh
i i know that we disagree with the
department but uh we feel that
any allowing of paying for religious
instruction by the state would violate
state and federal constitutions
i know that's going to be discussed
further so
yeah so um and i i would like to allow
attorney bond to do this but it falls
back to the conversation relative to oh
you know the rule and the law are quite
clear that of what is an allowable
expense what is not an allowable expense
so just as religious instruction as
the jail card attorney has pointed out
would be ineligible it would be
ineligible because it would be
non-constitutional right and so we don't
enumerate everything in this rule that
would be non-constitutional um there are
other expenses that would be not allowed
and so not only could you not you know
in this catch-all of oh wrap up
religious instruction because that would
become ineligible you would also not be
able to wrap up uh you know instruction
for i think we would mention a student
to become you know an airline pilot
right because that doesn't fit into the
category of oh
and then i'd like to attorney bond to
weigh in really on some of the legal
aspects relative to the
constitutionality
thank you so um
i just wanted to clarify with the ols
comment that
that they know they disagree with the
department about the
um
application of funds for religious
instruction i don't think there actually
is a disagreement so i i reviewed um
the aclu's letter that they sent to the
committee yesterday or at least the
department received it yesterday
um
and i don't think i think we're a lot
closer uh than that letter indicates so
the
the department agrees that it would be
impermissible to spend the funds on
religious instruction um we're aware
that where the
we agree we do agree with that point
where we disagree is this issue with the
catch-all language so i'd refer the
committee again to our letter of
february 15th page six where we list the
case law um numerous course uh cases
from new hampshire supreme court where
when there's a list with broad language
there's a common rule of general
statutory construction that those other
instances must be comparable to the
specific examples in the list so because
of that because there's nothing that
implies religious instruction in that
list we don't believe that religious
instruction is implied
um nevertheless
even if someone were to read the statute
that way it would be clearly
unconstitutional in our view um so we
would in our contractual relationship
with the vendor in this program the
scholarship organization that they
certainly understand that that's our
understanding that that's not a
permissible use of these funds
and as the commissioner said
it goes without saying that the
constitution is part of the
of the law of the land it doesn't need
to be that particular constitutional
provision need not be specified here and
at the exclusion of others and also
because we have this this list if we if
we with the broad catch-all that's
supposed to be read in the way that or
that we believe is supposed to be read
in the way we've described in our letter
if we start enumerating items that
specifically funds can't be used for our
concern is that other things that the
funds clearly can't be used for will by
implication there be be acceptable and
we think that will be confusing for
members of the public so we we agree
that a reuse of religious funds
our use of funds for religious
instruction would be unconstitutional um
and we think it it uh is such an obvious
point that it need not be articulated in
the rule to the exclusion of other
things that would also be impermissible
and then there's other factors too
um
you know the department in in navigating
this we have to be mindful of the
constitutional requirements under both
the new hampshire and the state and the
federal constitutions
and
under the federal constitution there's
both an establishment
clause and a free exercise clause that
we have to balance those
to to to spell out one part of it which
this would be like an establishment
clause problem
that we'd be addressing in the rule to
do that and not also weigh in on free
exercise issues that may come up in the
adjudications it it just seems
inappropriate to the department to have
essentially a treatise on constitutional
law in the rules when the it so it is
true we know and correct me if i'm wrong
funds are going to religious schools
correct
right and so
those schools
okay we're they are not constitutional
scholars i'm a lawyer i don't know the
law in every every single area
if you agree that that that use is
unconstitutional then why wouldn't you
put why wouldn't you put that
in the stat in the rule i don't i guess
i'm not understanding the objection
because it's such a clear violation of
the constitution right
why and right so it's not in the statute
they can't go to the statute i i don't
understand the objection to actually
putting that in the rule to provide
clear guidance to our taxpayers to
provide clear guidance to the
organizations that are receiving this
money that this is not permissible you
know the money is going to religious
schools how do i know as a taxpayer that
they're not going to use that money for
religious instruction how do i know that
yeah so as a taxpayer i would hope that
you would know the u.s constitution and
you would know that that would be a
prohibited activity and therefore would
be unallowed but just to your first
point
we believe that by including one
exclusion will confuse the law because
by a numerous what you're not allowed to
spend it on by default then parents
might say well they didn't call out be
training to be an airline pilot
therefore that must be an allowable
expense right and so we go back to the
law and the statute which clearly
enumerates and says here's what you can
spend it on as opposed to trying to
enumerate all the things you can't spend
it on and so in that affirmative
argument we provide clarity to
um you know all of our constituents who
are going to have to apply this does it
fit into one of these categories on the
list if so then you're all set and
you're good to go and so we think that
picking one item that would be
disallowed and quite frankly an item
that's disallowed and fairly
ubiquitously understood is you know
through the constitutional uh activities
that have taken place that we create
confusion for those same families rather
than saying here's what you
affirmatively can
adopt i would i would just agree that
it's ubiquitously understood by the
public attorney moral and um
i don't think this requires an
exhaustive list or a treaty treatise on
what cannot be included i mean
if you look at not just o in 194 f2 but
all of 194
f
2 a through o
you can look at things that says
curricular instructional materials
programs
and we know that the large majority of
the funds the education no not the funds
but the educational providers our
religious schools
so reading that list
and not being a lawyer there's no reason
that they wouldn't think that they could
use the funds towards educational
instruction
it would be a very simple fix and i
don't think it's going to open pandora's
box to well you didn't say this so we
can do it
so if i might just respond to that and
then
you know the other thing that you have
to consider is the application of that
too because these
funds are prohibited from
being used for religious instruction
so i have many of my public schools
today who offer world religion classes
right and they're studying hinduism and
buddhism christianity and judaism and so
that is that to be considered religious
instruction because they have uh looked
at that no and so one of the and i think
we would all readily agree on that and
so again we are very clear in terms of
what's enumerated in terms of what's
permissible and
religious instruction is prohibited and
that's prohibited by the constitution so
that's how we see that
representative ruler thank you
well i happen to agree with the two
people sitting on either side of me
i do not think that there is a problem
being very clear
when there is an issue
even here in this room
that is
religious in nature
we can make it because we all are
wardsmiths here
so that it is very clear
that religious instruction
is prohibited
now we can define
instruction if you'd like
but i agree that we need to have
something put in here because i'm a
lawyer and i don't know what that is so
i don't think it's as clear in all due
respect
that you think it is
well you know senator whitley asked for
a clarification of whether funds are
going to religious schools right now
it would be unconstitutional if school
if we were to if the department were to
have taken this law and said well we
aren't going to let any of these funds
go to religious schools
that
itself would be unconstitutional so
there are the constitutional
issues here are fairly complex there and
the the case law that uh the aclu relied
on in their letter the carson case
that's currently in front of the supreme
court the this you know has the
potential to be a somewhat changing
landscape and uh the issues are complex
enough that it's not
in the department's view it's not
simple to to simply
make a categorical
uh
uh constitutional explanation in there
given the case-by-case nature of these
expenditures like for example the
commissioner was leaning into world lang
world religion classes that maybe teach
about a religion which would not
constitute religious instruction
as we've talked about with the neces the
necessity of the catch-all that the
legislature decided was needed to
implement this
there could be circumstances that come
before the scholarship committee or the
scholarship organization
that straddle these lines these free
exercise and um
establishment clause lines that are
still still in some cases emerging and
sometimes very complicated you've got
cases like lock versus davie and the
carson case and the espinoza case and
you know it's just it
given that the department is clear is
clear with a scholarship organization
that funds cannot be used for religious
instruction we think it would uh it's
unnecessarily redundant to include that
language in here and if we were to
include it it could cause confusion in
the other direction it could it could
cause people to think well i can't use
this fund for a religious in at a
religious institution um and that would
have its own constitutional
ramifications so we just think there's
the potential to create more confusion
and i guess i would just like add one
more thing to that is that we have not
mitigated by not including that language
in this law the aclu or anyone else's
opportunity if they believe that
uh you know for example a religious
school that's receiving funds from this
is violating the constitution by using
these funds for
uh you know religious instruction they
have the ability to uh pursue that
constitutional claim against that entity
so we you know
to to attorney bond's point you know
this is
as as word smithy as we can be it's not
a clear-cut thing and it is a dynamic
landscape and so we have to be careful
that we don't set ourselves up to create
more confusion
representative mcguire yes thank you i'd
like to move to approve this rule
with the
request that the department work with
the legislature regarding
the legislative issues that have that
have been noted
and also the large number of bills in in
process and also that the department
report
to the
edge to the legislature
on
in more detail on the issue of
religious instruction because
i don't unlike representative roulard i
don't think we can
today give you a
some language that you could insert into
the rule um i'll second that motion
and i do have something to say
representative lang to speak to the
motion
thank you
just to speak to the religious aspect i
i agree i think for me you're gonna
catch 22. i think if you put down
something about religious instruction
then people are going to automatically
assume you can't go to religious school
without understanding what that law
particularly means when you use that
phrase religious instruction so i think
you're in a really tough spot to try to
define that but i probably need to make
a best guess effort and see try to do
something like that
i just think we're confusing the idea of
religious schools with religious
instruction and those are getting
complicated together and we allow the
use for religious schools we don't allow
the use of religious instruction and
trying to define that's a great try but
i agree that the rules should be adopted
as it's written now and you should work
with the legislature to see if there's
something we can do to clarify that in
the future
okay we have a motion to
conditionally approve the discussion
representative tucker thank you i served
nine years on the wellesley
massachusetts school board
my children most of the time attended
that public school
so i am very familiar with the
difficulties
of coming up with
how to deal with this whole topic
and in wellesley
they had a two-year course social
studies course which i called the roots
of western civilization
and it had some other bland name
and we skipped that we went from greece
and rome egypt you know the ancient
civilizations
right through
the dark ages
and then we skipped the reformation and
the renaissance
and they picked up at the french
revolution
because
the town was
primarily christian but
many were roman catholic many were not
and so this whole topic
of study versus instruction
i think really does need to be worked on
because it affects
what is included
in
the curriculum
those children who left out a thousand
years
of western civilization
were not as educated as they should have
been
so i think it is i'm happy to support
your
emotions if
when you repeat it
can make sure that it includes a
definition or instruction or work on
that i would be happy to support it
senator whitley
thank you mr chair i certainly cannot
support that motion i think that you
know we joker has an obligation
in reviewing
in reviewing these rules um
to
i think
importantly make sure that we don't
violate the public's trust by allowing
uh a program with so many questions to
be implemented particularly when it
comes to our scarce and precious
taxpayer dollars
you know the committee can you know
looking at the potential objections in
rsa 541 a 13-4 there are four bases for
objection and i think we have
heard ample testimony from what we've
received from the aclu from drum and
woodson from a whole host of other folks
from the jalcar staff you know i
i believe that the gel car staff
take an impartial look at every rule and
i and i respect them deeply and they
have pointed out to us a whole host of
concerns and so i think there are four
bases for an objection for this rule you
know and i think of course you know we
talk about this a lot in gel car
regardless of your policy position on
the actual program we're done with that
but we have an obligation
right to
to look at at this rule making make sure
that it complies
uh right that's not in um that it
doesn't violate public interest that
it's not contrary to the intent of the
legislature that it's beyond the scope
of the agency and on that latter point
beyond the scope beyond the authority of
the scope of the agency we heard from
jal carr staff right that there is not
adequate criteria for the scholarship
organization to adjudicate where the
expense is eligible i mean i think this
is this raises a significant question
about the breadth and scope of the
scholarships role and authority to
manage public funds and that the
delegation of authority to the
scholarship organization is very
problematic and then i think the
not adding a simple sentence into the
rule that funds received by a school
under this program shall not be used for
religious instruction a very simple
sentence to clarify how public funds are
going to be used to
to show the public that we are doing our
due diligence to not violate the
constitution that is a simple fix and
you know without that there's no way
that i could support an approval thank
you
diane
thank you mr chair um
i basically agree with representative
ruriart and senator whitley i i don't
feel that i can support this at this
time i think it still needs work thank
you
we still have that okay
mike can you give us tell us what the
motion what you have for a motion
approval with recommendation that the
agency work with the
legislature
to resolve issues and to work on the
outstanding legislation
i'm not sure if i captured that entirely
or
there was also the caveat that they
report to us
on how they implement
the constitutional requirement to not
fund religious instruction
okay
okay we'll do a roll call vote
no
and
i will call the roll representative
roulard
senator whitley no
senator ward yes
senator gray yes
chair votes yes representative mcguire
yes
representative schuett
no
representative lang yes
and representative tucker
is that known
yes
the motion passes six to three
and we have the item removed from the
consent calendar
this is uh 2021-117
yes
it is
regarding
disbursement of child support payments
committee staff have no comments
yes i pulled this for consent
because when i read the cover letter
it says
that
the provision is explicitly detailed in
federal laws the department elected to
remove this provision from the rule as
it would prevent the department from
having the ability to act on an
immediate federal law or regulation
change or waiver
i have no objection to them implementing
federal laws
but we are
we are constitutionally forbidden from
accepting a
change a federal rule without explicit
vote of an elected body
so therefore i
am strongly opposed to this rule
good morning um allison zeno
administrator of the administrative
rules units for the department of health
and human services
um i apologize the program experts are
not here we did not expect this to be
pulled off the consent calendar however
i was able to speak with someone in the
the unit
and
if we add back in the federal regulation
that explicitly
allows the department to
um hold this monies
would that satisfy
yes that way we would be voting on a an
explicit rule
and not leaving it open for
cms or whomever it is that writes this
rule to change it without our approval
which is what we don't allow
which we do not have the authority to do
um
so my suggestion
then would be
to add back in an eye
and then
it would read something of the sorts
intercepted federal tax refunds made to
satisfy
a non-for a debt that are associated
with a joint tax return shall be held in
accordance with 42 usc
a3b we need a date
we need a specific version of that that
rule in order to approve it
mike um
i would have to say that depends if they
are compelled to uh comply with a cfr
like des for a lot of things
then a data is not needed if they are
choosing to comply with a cfr on their
own then yes a data is needed
the department is required um
is required to abide by that and our
rule actually stated
that the department was required to hold
for six months but the actual the
federal regulation had changed and it's
not to exceed six months
the unit then opted to
just try to remove that from their rule
altogether that way it would just
default to the federal regulation
however
we i have authority to allow
to put that back into the rule
mr
but notwithstanding what i said if
representative mcguire would like that
language in there then
that could be part of her motion
i would like to have it explicit and not
leave it hanging
because
whether we're required to follow federal
regulations or not
they're not
that's totally unconstitutional
allison could you send us that exact
language please yes
so that would be an a conditional
approval including that language
correct
so you've heard the motion any
discussion from the committee
seeing on all those in favor
aye
opposed
the motion carries
i'm sorry who made the motion and
seconded
i think
i'll second it but i think carol made
the motion
so we'll try that again i'll make the
motion mr chair that we are
conditionally approved with the language
uh as provided by the agency entered
into the rule motion by lang second by
gray
can we restate the motion
so that was a motion to conditionally
approve by lange to
include a language from the agency and
the second by grade
you've heard the motion again
all those in favor aye
opposed
the motion carries
is that all our business today
um
if you could hang on for a moment there
are a couple things i'd like to bring up
under other business
okay we'll cancel a continue meeting
yeah
for the committee members
on tuesday
i staff met with
the chair and the vice chair we do that
every month before the jail car meeting
to go over the agenda
one of the items we discussed is a
concern that over the last two years
certainly since
code started there has been almost a 50
reduction in rule making
that was probably understandable for a
while but it seems to can be continuing
and the chair and vice chair expressed a
concern
and we have
just late yesterday gotten a report from
it indicating what rules are expiring
from 21 through 23. the reason being is
in the fall of 2011 the law changed to
make rules go from eight years to 10
years
subsequent to that there was a lot of
rule making over the next couple of
years to get 10 10-year rules in place
and a lot of those are going to be
expiring
this year and next year and the agencies
do not seem to be
picking up to take care of that so we
are going to send out a letter after
it's reviewed by the chair and vice
chair
to let people know about that
the other thing
i probably shouldn't have to mention
maybe i don't but i will mention
you've obviously all known that
committee staff at every meeting is
wearing face masks i just want to assure
everybody that is not a political
situation all three of the staff members
staff lawyers have chronic medical
conditions and it would make it to a
various situation if serious situation
if we got a virus
the committee appreciates that
any other items
no sir
go ahead
so
maybe we ought to be thinking
as a committee
it's embarrassing for me as an alternate
to be the one recommending it but some
kind of extensions
for certain
agencies that are falling behind on
getting things renewed there's process
in place because what i understand
sitting on ways and means we're hearing
about bills
where
apparently rules have not been able to
keep up quickly
with
changing situations
and and that i think comes first and the
one i'm thinking of particularly
has to do with
allocations of
monies received from
opioid
adjudications and settlements
and
it
is spoken of as you know money is
sitting that could be used
but the rules aren't
haven't been
worked out
and and that's come up on a couple of
others that
offhand i can't
think of what they were but
as someone who's even associated as an
alternate i don't like hearing this i
think that
new materials
always should come before extensions
so i just
well all the rules have
uh unless there had been a final
objection have uh
the
value of a law
they're presumed legal and valid and
you must comply
regardless of whether it's a brand new
rule or one that has been in place for
10 years and now the agency wants to
extend it
if those rules go out of effect
it's the same whether it's a new rule or
an old rule
you can no longer enforce those rules
and we do have mechanisms in 541a
to allow agencies to take some variants
like adopting an interim rule for six
months because an agency's rule is about
to expire
you can
there
you can start a rule even before a
statute goes into effect if you know
there's going to be a new law as long as
the rule does not go into effect before
the law
so there are some measures in place
representative mcguire
yes thank you i hate to drag this out
but
the rules are valid for 10 years and
then they expire
and we have seen
so many cases where the agency comes in
and says oh god our rules expired two
years ago
and we haven't done anything on it what
i believe the staff memo is intended to
do is to say here's your rules are going
to
expire shortly
if you need to change them then start
rulemaking if you think they're pretty
good already then just
renew them as is
and i think that that's what we need to
do is have them think about the fact
their rules are expiring because
if they don't they're going to end up
with expired rules that they can't
enforce
yes and
the reason for us running that report
was specifically to do that to let some
of these agencies know this is happening
one of our problems is that our database
doesn't allow us to kind of pull this
information easily
and to keep track of it and that is
something that we're moving forward with
with it to fix that problem in the
future so in the future we'll be able to
kind of ping an agency maybe a year out
of an expiration and let them know so
hopefully that will eventually be
resolved but for now we're doing it
manually
okay
with that the meeting is adjourned
all right
[Music]
i think i did see a notice come through
i'm assuming it's going to be an exact
session
because we've heard all the public
hearings right oh well we
might have i know we wouldn't make
notice for the bills we passed yesterday
you